perché c'è una palma e gli agenti
ragazzi e questo nuovo video che non fa
vj oggi sono qua con email di nuovo
siamo tornati per ragazzi non abbiamo
ancora fatto niente vi prego siamo
ritornati perché l'altra volta abbiamo
fatto il quiz dove loro rispondevano
alle mie domande
oggi io risponderò alle domande su email
se sbagli cosa succede non lo voglio
sapere se sbaglio non lo voglio sapere
cosa succede se sbagli cosa succede tu
sei capelli giuseppe i capelli rosa
perché mi avete attaccato una roba
corale era una pro con cosa iniziato
tecnico lo stesso verso non lo so e non
chi lo sa non è stato però io lo so io
[Musica]
l'antenna che si capisce meglio i nostri
video
vai avanti ma che voglio più fare ma
qual era il nickname di sterline
gameplay prima di terni uniti facendo
veramente sto provando scotch non è
indebolita mentre dritto come si chiama
la ragazza di anima marcello vederla in
pagine di specchi dove ha fatto step
mille soggetti lì ho capito il suo
ultimo tatuaggio e cosa rappresenta al
di legge nelle 16 20 c'è la sua gamba
detto a bellissima perché lo aiuti ma
perché un poverino allora è una
lucertola sicuro ma non mi ricordo seria
ibiza formentera credo sei fortunato
basta c'è un'altra domanda su stefanoni
una veloce un altro sousse tecniche non
abbiamo ancora fatto sistema poi è la
stessa cosa sempre stato chi si è fatto
il tatuaggio sul braccio tecnico la sala
uci
qual è il pupazzo preferito di stima
molto il calcio ma poi sono semplici
sono troppo semplice non lo sapevo
ci sono già in tutti i video hot hot 41
29 lo ha detto lui vale per la destra e
la sinistra non vale me l'ha detto sul
ma perché tutto in testa wilson non
conosceva perché ce l'hai anche dietro
anche quando parlammo regolato ragazzo
esistono anche le braccia e le gambe
perché soprattutto in testa porta fa
malissimo ragazzi fa malissimo porca
[ __ ] o cosa ha fatto anima con la
sabri gamer e degli amici a rimini
vorrei dire una cosa ma non posso dirlo
ma io che cazzo ne so invece le leggi le
leggi hanno insultato la polizia hanno
notato in piscina tutta la notte non
penso conoscendoti antigiuridico risciò
e vita si chiamava quali sono i colori
di surraco cesa ha risposto a circa di
quanto più in ordine allora giallo verde
blu e rosso allora tu sei rosso blu
verde giallo male napoletto maledetto
male ora di tutto con le piccola di
tutto 20 20 poi nominato i ragazzi
wheels avanti avanti il trio è composto
da e [ __ ] allora anima non c'era
quindi prima si ragazzo si qual è il
cognome di suri al palo edificio sono
sanissimi grande ha mancato la rete un
altro un altro sasha cosa significa in
italiano è facile guerra di calcolo
sasha ha ricambiato da da da da
salvatore no hai detto di no quindi non
è salvatore ma dargli un aiuto ma perché
vuole aiutarlo lui non è alessio
alessandro veramente large alexandra ex
alessandro ma che cazzo vuol dire basta
ea poverino così non si muove i toni no
non l'hai fatto davvero che questo gioco
divertente perché siamo messi scrive il
nome di anima schiaccia si aspetta
questo è difficile partecipato al video
di anima e lo sobri gamer che colorano
vestiti da giocare a m a
io partecipo pubblico
mai hanno un braccio io voglio finire in
questo video vanno ad un'incollatura
siamo sia mesi dove è nato lega ma
troppo facile aveva messo ridotto che ti
lamenti tavolo in quale regione anche di
chi non sono ancora mai andati mail ci
fosse serio io ci sono stato lì non
abbia fatto in quale canzone appaiono
email che ne sanno di maiale sale 2000
fine e mezzo è stato punto da una vespa
è che ne so io dio mio che so ma non lo
so neanche io solo il vostro medico
personale non lo sono anch'io un aiuto
florido freni lo scotch era gli 8 più a
muoverlo basta lo scotch
basta come si chiama la sorella hai una
sorella
grazie angela angela nozze ma che fai a
diete non ho mai visto regali che basta
display nono telecamera 03 chiamato
staccata cosa sta a casa ragazzi non al
100 iscritti vegas perché continua
ascoltare la gente guarda vino mi guardi
guardavi lanciato anche un tema che sta
ascoltando tutti come si chiama sfugge
il mio amico ma dai ma che si chiama
tutti dicono basta
vabbè ragazzi speriamo che questo video
vi sia piaciuto l'ho sempre comanda ed
aventi diritto
qualche dritta dritta mi ha detto papà
palazzotto vincolato a foiera che gli
usa telecomando a era poi rialzarsi non
vedo che non so spero che questo video
vi sia piaciuto ragazzi ringrazio email
per aver partecipato a questa bellissima
e dolcissima sfida voglio troppo bene
sono felice di avervi incontrato
guardare video non messo del suo per
avrei capito se avesse ragazzi quasi
20mila lasciato sgomento è un mi piace
al capo cieli facebook come lottato la
definizione o muoverti matteo sanna
questi dischetti di ci vediamo un
prossimo video no no no no davvero ciao
a tutti i fatti di fatima a questa è la
vendetta di wilson sono staccate come
come sei attaccato si può auto basic ma
figlia togli la mano grazie mille
ma è stato piacere andiamo se no che poi
beh anche qui ci vieni con noi addio
addio mio amico lorenzo va bene papà